you're known for playing a whole host of
uh fairly unhinged characters that would
be outside of a lot of people's Comfort
zones
um but I think Nemo even takes that a
little bit further than a lot of stuff
you've done so far
um what was the most challenging or
exciting part of taking a role that
relies so heavily on your own
performance I don't you know I don't
think of in terms of challenges because
it was a pleasure to do I suppose I
suppose the idea is sometimes
it was important to inhabit it and you
had to
uh connect the narrative and you didn't
want to point at it so it was always the
challenge was to be disciplined not to
indicate anything and to only deal with
what was before us which was helped
greatly by the fact that we were
shooting in chronological order so there
was a kind of practicality and a kind of
present mindedness that really guided us
with this film it really hammers home
how art is a um
at its most valuable as a means of human
expression
um can you speak a bit about how acting
is so deeply linked to that concept uh
as an actor an artist yourself okay I'll
try
um you know uh I I think for me broadly
speaking we could this is a whole
conversation that could take years but
you know the beauty the beautiful thing
for art uh for me is it it opens
something it it opens our mind to a
certain kind of mystery because art it's
really hard to explain it in uh daily
terms okay daily life terms so it
encourages us to think and question in a
new way and hopefully acting does that
same thing when we
uh make events or or commit to doing
things or or make a story that make
people reconsider their lives or
question things or if think in new ways
that's exciting that's what keeps Us
Alive curiosity
um you know dealing with the Unseen uh
you know these things you can reach them
various ways you know you can reach them
through uh nature through religion
whatever but also through ART in general
uh it can it can Elevate our lives so
this movie has been a long time in the
making but now it's coming out sort of
in a post lockdown World
um can you speak to how we can all sort
of relate to Nemo a little bit more now
you know just being trapped not being
able to go out trying to figure out how
your life has been disrupted and how are
you going to proceed and your your
future is uncertain of course he has a
lot worse than us because when we were
in the pandemic
it was a collective experience and we
were all going through it so there was a
great comfort in that
um or not great some comfort in that uh
where Nemo is very different because it
is true solitude
not only has he
uh had something uh you know he's trying
to do a crime and it goes bad that's
that's where it starts but
he's plucked from his life and put into
a completely different situation and
it's it's uh
the heat is much turned up much more on
him than it is on us but I think of
course as audiences watch this they're
going to think of their experience in
the pandemic and it'll may also make
them a little more empathetic to this
guy Nemo I would be remiss to ask if I
didn't ask
um you're teaming up again soon with uh
Robert Eggers for Nosferatu is there
anything you can tell us about
um what you're excited for in that role
or when filming starts oh I I just love
working with Robert Eggers I I had a
wonderful time I you know I saw the
Witch and I liked it so much I
arranged a meeting with him we liked
each other then I did the lighthouse
which was a fantastic experience and I
think is very good movie then I did a
little part in the Northman which I
really enjoyed and now I get to do this
so I'm just happy to be back with him
it's nosferato his version of Nosferatu
this is uh why I have this mustache and
that um because we're shooting now uh
I'm I'm uh I start in just a little bit
um
I'm just excited to be with him again uh
he's a great filmmaker and I enjoy his
company is there anything
I'd say is entirely unique and like
that you
that stands out to you just that uh you
know sometimes it uh this director
um first time feature it's risky
uh it's a particular kind of movie
and you roll the dice and for me this
time
uh you know it came up Snake Eyes thank
you so much for taking the time to chat
with me uh this is great